MELINDA EPLER:
I'm Melinda Epler.
WAYNE SUTTON: I'm Wayne Sutton.
We're the founders
of Change Catalyst.
We empower inclusive and
sustainable innovation
globally.
MELINDA EPLER: Welcome
to this series sponsored
by Women Techmakers,
Google's program that
provides visibility,
community, and resources
for women in technology.
Together we're helping tech
hubs to develop more inclusive
cultures, programs, and spaces.
WAYNE SUTTON: Let's start
with external programs.
They are the key
driver in developing
a more inclusive tech ecosystem
in your city, town, or region.
These programs might
include events--
MELINDA EPLER:
startup office hours--
WAYNE SUTTON: lunch-and-learns--
MELINDA EPLER: evening classes,
training, workshops, and more.
WAYNE SUTTON: We know a thing
or two about hosting events,
as our own company,
Change Catalyst,
hosts tech inclusion
conferences, career fairs,
and startup showcases
attracting thousands
of attendees each year.
Events can expand your
reach and exposure
to under-represented
communities.
Opening your doors to
diverse programming
can broaden your networks for
internal hiring, membership,
mentors, instructors, et cetera.
MELINDA EPLER: Creating diverse
programs takes work, though.
For example, when Wayne and I
were developing our first tech
inclusion conference, which is
an event focused on solutions
to diversity inclusion,
we realized with about 2/3
of the speakers signed
up, that we were still
missing some key demographics,
specifically Latinos--
not Latinas, just Latinos--
veterans, and people
with disabilities.
So we took the time to widen
our network, put in the work,
and rounded out
the diverse lineup.
WAYNE SUTTON: Diverse
people are out there.
We just might not know them.
It takes time to
broaden your network.
But through research and asking
questions, you'll reach them.
Sometimes it's as
easy as asking friends
on social media for
diversity and inclusion
experts or diverse speakers.
Also check out some of the
resources we listed below.
MELINDA EPLER:
Partnering with programs
that focus on diverse
community signals
that your organization cares
about and values inclusion.
WAYNE SUTTON: Invite
diverse organizations
to host their events
in your facility
or in partnerships
with your organization.
MELINDA EPLER: Then
give them the space,
support them as much
as you can, and spread
the word about their
event to your networks.
WAYNE SUTTON: And
remember, it's not
enough to simply
host diverse people.
You need to show up, meet them,
and let them know you care.
Establish partnerships
to help spread
the word of your programs
to more diverse groups.
You can exchange
exposure on your website
as an incentive for the group.
Pay to put an ad
in the newsletter.
Or find another creative
way to work together.
If it's an event
you share, offer
a promo code for the community
and a free ticket to join you.
MELINDA EPLER: To develop a
truly inclusive and diverse
event, here are some
things to consider.
Topics-- make sure
that your event topics
appeal to diverse audiences.
WAYNE SUTTON:
Speakers-- speakers
should fully
represent the audience
you are trying to reach.
Make sure that they
are diverse in terms
of gender, race, ability, age,
and other characteristics.
MELINDA EPLER: Outreach--
while promoting your events,
always look for different
networking channels that
include under-represented
individuals.
WAYNE SUTTON: Timing--
the timing of an event
can make a big
difference to people
who are parents,
caregivers, currently
working, or commuting.
MELINDA EPLER: Cost--
consider a sliding scale.
Give discount or free
codes to new communities.
And even make some events free.
WAYNE SUTTON:
Accessibility-- make
sure you ask for accessibility
needs and requests ahead
of time on your website
and email communication.
MELINDA EPLER: And
if someone requests
a sign-language interpreter,
live captioning, a guide,
or something else, make
sure that person has what
they need to fully
participate in your event.
If you need help with this,
check out the resources below.
WAYNE SUTTON: Code of conduct--
a code of conduct is an
indicator to many people
that you care about
creating an inclusive event.
Make sure you post
this on your website
and in the physical
space and share on stage
at the beginning of events.
MELINDA EPLER: Photos--
nothing says inclusion
like visual representation.
Include diverse photos
in the presentation
slides and marketing materials.
And also consider having
diverse people look through
your slides, photos,
and other marketing
materials to make sure you
haven't accidentally included
imagery that might
offend someone.
Supply chain
diversity can be one
of the most impactful
opportunities
to expand your diversity goals.
Look at using services
or products founded
by local under-represented
entrepreneurs.
WAYNE SUTTON:
Consider every vendor
you use, from software vendors
to office supplies to food
in your cafe and
any subcontractors.
You might consider adding
to your hub's values
or formal process to prioritize
hiring under-represented people
as vendors.
MELINDA EPLER: Studies show
that companies with supplier
diversity programs
are more profitable
and promote innovation by
introducing new products
and services.
WAYNE SUTTON: Plus, it's
good for your local economy
and the community.
MELINDA EPLER: Diversifying
your partnerships,
events, and vendors can quickly
change your hub's reputation
as a place where diverse
people are welcome and belong.
A little extra work up front
to diversify your networks
can make a big difference
in the makeup of your hub
down the line.
WAYNE SUTTON: For
more information
about Women Techmakers,
Change Catalyst,
and additional resources,
see the links below.
MELINDA EPLER: Share this
series with your community.
And let's work together to
create inclusive tech hubs
around the world.